it was my great pleasure to invite on
stage monica salah the CTO of orange
spain is mala senior who is the CTO of
vodafone spain fernando Molina CTO of
mass mobile and last but not least our
keynote speaker who is joining us for a
discussion today
Enrique Blanco global CTO of telefónica
fiber-rich recipes are extremely
important and we are in a country which
if we call that kind of a kitchen it
would be basically a three-star Michelin
awarded kitchen and we have the top
chefs of those fibre recipes right here
with us so it would be a great pleasure
to hear from you all about what you
think are the key ingredients that have
pushed fiber and have enabled you the
leaders of the industry to deploy fiber
and how to make it a business success I
will invite first of all Fernando to
deliver his opening statement thank you
well I'm coming here representing the
the smallest of the fourth operators in
in Spain and the latest entrant in in
the market so somehow our position is a
slightly different from from the others
probably when you talk Telefonica
bonnafon orange do all of you know who
they are I'm going to explain who are we
must Mobile which is probably much less
known this is basically our history mass
modulus a brand I started as an MVNO
in the year 2006 and started operations
in 2008 but as an MVNO so clearly our
situation was after several mergers of
very small Spanish telco operators some
NBA knows some specialized
niche business operators in dear 2015
for the first time we considered
becoming an operator having its own
fixed access network and it happened
because orange acquired just tell which
was the fourth Spanish operator in the
fixed market and the European Commission
decided that they had to sell some
assets to maintain the competitiveness
in the market we were the ones bidding
for that access those access assets and
so in the year 2015 we acquired some
assets of fixed network so that we could
start having our own fixed network on
the mobile Sal side still being an MVNO
and we started selling convergence in
2016 and in 2016 we also acquired joy Co
which was the fourth mobile operator in
in Spain what means that at that point
we became a convert an operator with
some mobile network some fixed network
but with the peculiarity that for
example yoga didn't have coverage all in
all the country but it had uncover it
for 85% of the population and the rest
was through a national roaming agreement
and in the case of fixed well we had
some coverage of around but if we wanted
to grow and had the possibility to offer
the service to more customers we needed
to reach agreements and to do some more
investments I'm putting here and the big
numbers on the comparison what what were
we at the end of 2015 and the estimated
values for the end of the 2017 so we
were a company with around 160 million
euros revenue we have gone to 1.2
billion euros a beta 11 million euros
very small company to 235 million euros
a bit the mobile customers we were
coming from MVNO 1/2 million customers
now close to 5 million customers
in fix we had some nice operations in
business side 25,000 customers we are in
fact going close to 1/2 million
customers and in terms of fix access
network what we had was the point 8
million building units that we had
acquired from Orange and right now what
you see there is 2.1 million building
units from our own plus 8.4 in
agreements mostly with orange wholesale
agreements so this is what we have right
now today a part of that we have some
ADSL access through some other
agreements that we also have with orange
and so I have to say we were really a
very late entrant in the market so is
not that we enter into the market a bit
later than the others but the market was
starting to develop but market was quite
developed when we decided that there was
an opportunity there for having a fourth
operator competing in the market and of
course that was kind of a challenge
because you cannot really compete in a
market like this one if you are going to
compete with much less coverage than the
rest of the operators and of course in
terms of volume of customers we started
from the scratch in 2016 so we had a lot
of things to do and to change if we
wanted to be a relevant pleasure in the
market so what you see that in this
black line is when we enter into the
market and this is basically the
situation we had to face so what was the
decision and what have we been doing so
that we can be competitive in the market
in a market like the Spanish one with
where telephonic as deploying very fast
and orange is following and Vodafone
hustles a significant footprint and
ultra broadband fix area well basically
what we had to do was to find our spot
where can we
contribute to a better development of
the market I mean should we go to the
big cities well all the other operators
had already done development likely not
economies of scale a lot of the
deployment had been done already through
Co investment between different
operators so coming later at a market
that was already developed with a higher
cost deploying borrowers and by
ourselves in places where there were two
or three net existing networks didn't
make any sense
so we decided to go to areas where there
was no competence or little competence
so that we could do two things one is
find an area where there could still be
commercial opportunities but as well
help reduce the digital divide so it's
great to see how it grows the number of
building units that are built in Spain
but it's true that the level of coverage
of homes passed depending on the size of
the populations is very different so we
have focused on delivering in those
areas where the populations are smaller
and the penetration was much lower and
basically this is what we done 90% of
our deployment in areas where there was
low competition and 65% even in
population areas with less than 20,000
inhabitants was does he not enough to be
competitive in the market clearly not so
we are committed to invest and we are
investing but the other part of what we
had to do there was a developed market
was to reach agreements with other
parties that were already in the
marketplace mostly orange with wholesale
agreements but also with some smaller
pleasures and these pleasures that work
in local in a specific local areas local
populations so that we could complete
our own coverage and enough foreign
national wide coverage of our service so
basically this is the approach we have
take as a very late entrant and that we
think that has allowed us to to be
competitive has have a
why the North coverage committed to
invest and to improve also the the level
of coverage in Spain and reduce the
digital divide with the resources that
we can really have an afford then
basically the system thank you thank you
very much Fernando next I would like to
invite monica seles CTO of orange spain
also one of the main challengers in the
spanish market good morning
first i would like to thank the event
organizers for inviting owners in spain
to this keynote session the objective of
my presentation is to share with you our
understanding of why spain is a fiber
rich country
before going into the reasons i like to
take a minute to show some figures of
how goes fast with fiber by the four
main spanish operators if I make any
mistakes don't worry they will correct
me in a country of 26 million households
Telefonica / official figures from the
third quarter of 2017 showed 11 18 point
6 million households pass aiming at
achieving 25 million by 2020 almost 100
percent of his famous orange rich in
eleven point three Vodafone had ten
point three million households in this
case including both FTTH and cable and
much more will reach 1.5 million and
their mission is to reach four point
five in summary Spain is a unique case
in Europe with an already very rich
fiber-optic deployment and plans to
reach almost 100 percent of households
and what are the main reasons for the
situation of fiber abundance in this lie
we show the main headlines first we have
to consider Spain's low roll out cost
thanks to a favorable Joe type
distribution the ability of that is the
second ingredient for a fiber-optic
deployment success
it is ADSL migration is also a lever to
span fiber of this deployment and
another important ingredient is that the
spanish players have reached several
sharing agreements that even further
improve fiber financials and finally the
two last ingredients are that Spain is a
highly convergent market with Spanish
players being big enough to cope with
the amount of investment needed in the
following slides I will elaborate on
each topic first topic roll out costs
two factors make roll out costs in Spain
less expensive than in other countries
first the fact that we can deploy on
facades in order countries like France
this is not possible
and additionally population is much more
concentrated in big cities in Spain than
in other countries for instance in Spain
50% of the households are in buildings
with more than eight households per
building
whereas in France for instance 44% of
the households are single-family
dwellings these two factors facades and
concentration result in lower cost per
household in Spain compared to other
countries in Europe second ingredient
that Spanish regulation has promoted the
use of income and tax which by the way
are in very good shape this factor has
allowed operators to deploy fiber optics
in many municipalities minimizing civil
works which is a key factor for fiber
development speed our estimation is that
that with more than 15,000 kilometers of
ducts that orange has list we have
reduced the time to market by 5 ADSL
migration as we all know retire a
meeting of investment is a relevant
factor when deciding to invest or not in
fiber optic deployment gaining customer
migration from a DSL to our own fiber is
a key factor to increase profitability
we
it means we are able to stop leasing the
ADSL access from telefónica if we take
order to Spain as an example we have
less than five years retired of an
investment which is a quick payback for
an infrastructure deployment fourth
ingredient sharing agreements as you can
imagine co-investment agreements are
also a key factor to lower the cost of
deployment in the specific case of
oranges pain we have been very active
from the beginning of our operation in
Spain in building up shielding
agreements with other operators for
instance in mobile network or Andromeda
phone half a shell in agreement since
2007 and it is still in force and valid
today for ft test deployment release is
quite long in 2012 just tell that was
bought by orange into three years later
reach an agreement with Telefonica of
co-investment in 2014 and reach a
co-investment
agreement with Vodafone resulting in
approximately 2.2 million households
whose course will help for each operator
and in 2017 orange has developed
different co-investment agreements with
the rest of the big players in the
market mass mobile and oskol tell we
really believe that the co investment is
the smarter way to deploy fibre optics
because of the curve reduction and time
to market converging market a Spain is a
highly converging market reaching 83% by
end of third quarter of 2017 which as
you can see on the bar graph is much
bigger than in France or Poland
why is this level of convergence more
attractive to fibre deployment because
being a highly converging market we have
more to win or more to lose with fibre
or in other words thanks to fibre we can
gain fixed customers as well as their
mobile lines or in other words the fibre
deployment is paid for by the fix and
the mobile services
unless ingredient players with a scale
an additional important point is that
there are 4 strong operators in Spain
which can make large investments on
infrastructure for the country as you
can see on the slide the photo operators
have a large customer base and financial
strength with healthy BDA rates to base
in fibre deployment to summarize I would
say that there are a special conditions
in the market that make a Spain number
one in Europe for fiber rollout from our
end I have to say that already Spain
feel my beliefs in a high value of
infrastructure as a way to deliver and
match services to our customers and
finally as a Spaniard I sincerely
believe that the fiber infrastructure
that we are building together in Spain
will be great for our country that's all
thank you very much thank you very much
Monica and I would like to ask is Mel to
deliver his opening statement so good
morning all
thank you very much first of all for
inviting me to do this to this so
important event to speak about with
fixed networks on how we are managing
the evolution of the fixed networks let
me start with something very basic sorry
for my voice but I assume I will survive
through the speed but because I'm not
getting very well today my name is they
said this is Madison Cowan currently the
CEO of water from Spain I'm going to try
to help you first so I'm not going to
show a slides and going just to speak a
bit openly to you to explain to you what
we have been doing in Spain and what is
more relevant what are the plans that we
have for mine about the things that we
are going to do in the future and what I
was thinking I said okay let's start
from the basics so why okay so why focus
on Spain is so relevant the NGA
infrastructure the NGA looking at it as
Nessie and erection
so ultra fast speed generation actresses
and there are a lot of reasons okay my
my great collies has tried to summarize
and I I fully agree with them so FTD is
Net Generation actors are more efficient
better networks I'm for sure can bring
us to the liberal much richer services
but that is one point and that was the
differentiation factors when the we were
thinking about the strategy a smaller
from Spain okay so one of our main
strategies is to offer the best service
to our customers okay so this is let me
say our real dream and they study
fashion of our customers is what we
really believe is going to give us the
differentiation of factors mess with the
rest of the things okay so if we put
that into account okay and you introduce
on that environment how relevant are the
NGA networks together with the mobile
ones is like a wonderful mix okay so we
are going to give to our customers
better services better network better
speeds much more quality and so on to
deliver to them a much better experience
with much more services and that was the
initial steps however I'm before to go
deeply on detail about as we as both
upon his paying has done who are doing
in this environment I think that the
first thing is we need to be proud when
I mean we I referred in for sure about
these guys that are here sitting with me
as telecommunication industry in Spain
okay also to our minister that was
speaking this morning unfortunate that
we represent today why I'm saying that
and I know just speaking about both
awfully Spain because I really believe
that the Spain has introduced a
differentiation factor what is that
differentiation factor today in Spain as
our minister was mentioning we are
covering more than the eighty-five
percent of our population with mga
networks what does it means
that in reality okay we have passed
already around the 70 percent of our
whole schools already with nga networks
if you compare that value that seven
percent comparing with other situation
in other markets the rest okay that the
typical values are around the twenties
in Spain we are around the 70s
okay and this is something that all of
us needs to be very proud of so we were
discussing what has been the key factors
to deliver this kind of results from my
personal point of view there are five
okay but I'm going try to explain to you
first one as our minister was mentioning
there is some regulatory frameworks that
are supporting us on the deployment of
this kind of networks secondly as you
can imagine and is very relevant is the
investment that we are doing and we have
done in these markets okay that has been
great and we are going to continue doing
that kind of thing son of this
investment that this is my third point
was just to make some consolidation
processes so the company that I
represented here today that is Vodafone
Spain made the acquisition of oh no some
years ago that means that we saw at that
moment that the conversion proposition
was so relevant that instead to start
building a building more ngnl work we
had quite the spread on fibre in Spain
that was oh no
and we consolidate that to companies
this is something that we did as Bala
phones penises Monica was mentioning
orange also did we just tell a bit later
for Fatah
he said what open mind okay and I need
to be also or very clear with that so we
have made different agreements a lot of
different agreements so we have some
agreements to Co built FTTH we are doing
our round ft d8 building we have share
with owners and we have plenty of
agreements there and on top of that we
have made other commercial agreements as
I will explain you later today to look
for the smartest way to reach to our
customers with the new and richest
services ok last but not least something
that the only speaking are also very
proud of is like we are in this
technology community I'm doing NGA
networks is not just doing deployment is
much more than that
so what do I mean ok we need to speak
and
innovation in technology okay and this
wall is everyday more and more relevant
so doing ng a deployment is not just
introducing the fiber to the house of
our customers the house of our customers
are going to be bad what already being
part of our nga network and this is key
okay and has being one of these five
factor that I was mentioning before to
start doing this kind of infrastructure
in Spain and to reach the moment where
we are okay that as I mentioned at the
beginning as an industry we have reached
till the 70% of our course calls in
Spain already with nga networks let's
move a bit under LSS picking out about
bola from Spain okay so there are a lot
of things that I cool mentioned today
but I am going to start again from the
basics so Ambala from Spain would really
believe on three things okay
that is a part of our reality ADIZ that
I really work with them in my technology
organization which are them so the total
satisfaction of our customers as I was
mentioning before this is the most
important thing that we are doing so try
to give to our customers the best
experience first second and things to
all the different values that we were
discussing today is the total
convergence okay so we would like to
increase as much as possible the
convergence rate you that we have in our
customer base why very easy honestly
speaking is because we are going to give
much better services to our customers
they are going to be much most loyal to
us as a company and at the same time
they are going to be more happy because
they are going to have additional
services but at the same time they are
going to have a much efficient bill to
the different operators third one is our
total digital what does it mean is like
we really believe that we would like to
offer to our customers a digital journey
to establish the connection with us and
for sure we are open in to then also to
this personal relationship if you take
these three things together and now we
are speaking about the networks
the net was our key to deliver these
three things okay
net was both mobile and fixed today we
are speaking here about fix but I will
mention something regarding also the
mobile because honestly speaking they
need to be together to ensure that we
are going to offer the capability the
capacity and the performance that our
juices need and they would like to have
so in the case of Vodafone Spain we are
currently having more than 20 million
households already covered with fiber
with nga technology more than 20 million
means okay that for a total more or less
of 28 million households that we
currently have in Spain we are covered
more than 70 percent how three things
okay
so I was mentioning before we have quite
Ono the fiber experts in Spain okay um
and we took our wonderful technology
that was the HFC technology that is
cable okay that are covered in more than
seven million households in Spain with
this technology what we are doing is
investing on them on the technology
itself agreed in the technology to
DOCSIS 3.1 to ensure that we are going
to have the cup the same capabilities
both in the age of signal war and in the
FTTH
this was the first point secondly that
is also very relevant is our FTTH
deployment we did some FTTH deployment
by ourself
we did some sharing agreement deployment
with orange building our FTTH agreement
and this gives us an additional more or
less three and a half million hostels
covered with fiber on top of that what
we considered and I can see that is our
obligation as an industry let's go to
look for the best potential sharing
agreements that we may have okay we
close one year ago a commercial
agreement with Telefonica
well we are let me say using that
infrastructure to connect it to our
customers and also we are using the
regulatory wholesales possibilities that
we have to ensure that we have the best
potential network to our customer
reaching as I was mentioning before more
than the 70% of the
Haskell's that we have in Spain but what
about the customers what are they doing
with that okay and this is very
important so the way that we are
approaching our customary season with a
convergent proposition is our both off
on one what does it means we are
offering to our customers in in a unique
proposition different services that they
can select so that can be 2 P 3 P 4 P
and more to come okay and today we are
offering the basic fix voice we are
putting on top of that let me say the
connectivity so the fiber and the speed
that they may have on top of that we are
introducing our derivative TB platform
already with 4k and with the main
functionalities that we can deliver to
them out on top of that we are offering
to them the best 4G network that we have
in this countries as followed by the
different p3 benchmark that we did um
the customer are answered in us with
that because only speaking a we're
combating proposition is working well
okay and is increasing more or less in
terms of number of combative customer
around 20-25 percent year-on-year
what is only speaking a good result and
this is just because as I was mentioning
before with the converging proposition
we really believe that they the main
object is that we have that is our
obsession to give to the customer the
best potential experience is what we are
doing through this kind of networks okay
so just to summarize I would say four
different things okay first of all as I
was mentioning and I really believe that
this is the reason because we are here
today as a Spanish industry and by the
way you are also here today in Spain due
to this we need to be proud of the
things that we have done in Spain and
hopefully the spirits that we are
selling with with you here today are
going to be useful in other places first
in secondly in bada phone we look for
the way that we consider this matter to
deliver our fiber not just because it's
relevant because our customer needs and
we really believe that that customer
differentiation experience is key for us
and this is
bass in our strategy and for that is the
reason because we had beat the largest
FTTH rng in other word that that is
today in Spain giving service to more
than 20 million whole schools in Spain
but important this is not a race okay
this is my my fault point so on top of
that the network is not useful enough if
we are not introducing the innovation
ingredients okay to the network to
ensure that we are going to continue
evolve this network to higher and higher
speeds okay today the maximum speed that
we are selling at least in Vodafone
Spain is one gigabit per second but it's
true that in the near future we will
need to do much more how through the
innovation an important piece as I was
mentioning at the beginning is the house
the content of the house this is
transforming what is a convergent
network the house in such a way is part
of our network and we need to be on top
of it with our tools with our
proposition because if not for the
customer is going to be the same if the
issues in the network if the issues in
the house because for them us and rigor
was also mentioning at the beginning for
them the only reality is the Wi-Fi and
the services that we are going to put
over the fibre okay thank you very much
big pleasure
[Applause]
thank you very much as well I have a few
questions to all of you
starting with Enrique and following up
on your very interesting presentation
you have spent a couple of slides on
explaining the industrialization process
that telefónica has carried out in fiber
deployment and clearly those have
resulted in considerable efficiencies
and cost savings for telefónica what are
the main efficiencies that you would
highlight that were gained through the
industrialization of deployment so thank
you as I mentioned before so it is
through that the volume it is key and we
are managing this this is relevant but
that's all it is relevant it is just
price and we can be sure that we are
acquiring the technology to the right
price so this is a must for us but we
are defining what we say that it is the
key topics trying to go through the
industrialization and it is the deep
knowledge what we are managing so this
means that processes technology tools
and when I say tools I say OSS and BSS
how the customer it is interacting with
us how we can go through the pew digital
experience of the customer with the
fiber as a key trying to warranty that
we are doing a simplification and this
means quality but this means efficiency
so and finally how we are managing the
end-to-end approach of all the
industrial process that we have this
include the whole connectivity in which
are the services that we are delivering
on the top so let me we are
industrializing not only how we are
managing the fiber in all over operation
we're in turn in this region however
customer they are interacting with us
with a very good example
does my Wi-Fi this is not only to get
the Wi-Fi ready is it is how you're
managing this Wi-Fi at home so and this
is not doing country by country it is
how we can build platforms because don't
forget that telephoning it is a platform
company how we can build platform with
services that our customer IDs in trying
to industrialize not only how we are
operating defining creating and
maintaining it is how we are doing one
in this relation in a pure digital
experience of our customers with our
assets so and this is the key and to be
honest in terms of efficiency we are now
starting in this way so once you control
the technologies you go to the pure
digital industry experience so getting
efficiencies but mainly getting
differentiation for our customers thank
you it also was quite interesting what
you mentioned on your very last slide in
in the context on the of the
simplification process the telephony Co
is driving through you have mentioned
your ambition with regard to copper
decommissioning and copper
decommissioning is very important from
several perspectives it is a very
important an equation actually in the
investment case for fiber but if we look
at the more technical perspective could
you please elaborate a bit more on what
the process of copper decommissioning
and fiber migration looks like from
telephony cos perspective and also I
would be very curious to know whether
you have set a definite of deadlines for
yourself for complete copper switch off
or is that your ambition no it you're
asking for the deadline it is very
similar if you're asking so when we will
be switching off the 2g or the 3d net go
so it will be a very question so and it
will be very tough so trying to say but
so from the migration how we can
maximize the efficiency switching off
our central offices were the ISIS on
familiar faces so how difficult it is to
manage the MDF in the central offices
how how much activity that it is good
for nothing but because it is very
expensive and it is not adding value to
the customer so we have a bold program
trying to switch off or the Commission
our central offices so we have our clear
in our statistical plan how many of the
ending will be close it but this is not
only technical we have all the technical
levers to do it but there is some
commercial so how we can guarantee that
our customer they will be ready trying
to migrate from copper to fiber if they
are not tacking some of the services
that we are offering associated to the
favor the second one it is we need to
fulfill all the regulatory topics so
what to do with the unbundle it so lines
that we have still today so fully
supported by the MDF and going through
the equipment within our own central
offices so that we have today so we have
a plan we are building it so if you are
asking me do we have a plan we will be
switching off all the central offices
not yet but we have a clear plan in the
next two three years trying to reduce
our complexity and the coast
but if the main coast it is not in the
central offices the main course it is in
the rest of the network that we have
today that by the way through a 4G
evolution by the way of the ftth we are
doing a huge simplification switching
off believe me hundreds of thousands of
equipment in transport that they are
consuming energy that they are consuming
a lot of activity in terms of
maintenance that there in sometimes in
phase out that we are closing we are
switching off in all our operation so
and this is really a real effective
efficiency maybe not so exciting to
close a central office but believe me in
terms of cost it is helping a lot and
the fiber with this key trying to do it
thank you I I think that this is this is
one of those topics which do not sound
extremely sexy if you like
but at the same time I actually really
think that we should be learning all at
a European level from the best practices
which are present in a Spanish market
and I also believe that the process of
copper decommissioning and ultimately
the process leading to switch off is
something that should be more discussed
and more visibly and openly put on the
political agenda of Europe because it is
a very key factor in the equation for
getting our future fiber networks into
place next I would like to turn to
Monika Monika orange Spain is obviously
the main challenger operator the second
challenger operatively if you like in
the Spanish market but you have a very
different incumbent position and the
French market as well as in the Polish
market and from your experience looking
at all these markets where or in Spain
as present does the market position that
you occupy the market position that you
take actually make a difference with
regard to the fiber investment case does
it make a difference whether you have an
existing copper network or not we think
that market position is not a driving
itself when deciding to how much to
invest in fiber for instance in the case
of orange all European countries are
investing quite heavily in Europe not
only France Spain and Poland but also
Romanian is Livadia are investing this
is why orange group is one of the main
telco operators deploying favored in
Europe having said that is true that the
business case is not the same for an
incumbent owning a Cooper Network than
for a new player for an incumbent I
suppose that one of the main key drivers
for deploying to deploy fibre is to get
rid of the maintenance of the Cooper
network which is not the case if you are
a new player on the other hand if you
are a new player like orange here
in Spain our key driver is our ability
to increase our profitability by
immigrating customers from a DSL to our
own fiber and at the same moment to
increase the quality of service
delivered to the customers thanks to
this new and advanced
ftth infrastructure that we are
deploying and I add the wifey the Wi-Fi
thank you
next I would like to turn to to is mal
this Mel you've mentioned in your
opening statement that you're actually
managing various technologies in the RNG
a network and not only that you're
you're also managing basically kind of
your own network wholesale access on a
regulated basis wholesale access on a
commercial basis so I wonder how you're
actually managing to patch all this
together into a ubiquitous in seamless
connectivity service this would be one
part of my question and the other part
would be and I think that is also
something that was touched upon my
Monica the the sharing agreements which
are quite prevalent in a Spanish market
do you expect this to be more of a trend
perhaps even across Europe an industrial
train that commercial deals will be
actually done by operators for a network
sharing and that some operators might
enter into this phase where they manage
different types of solutions own network
commercially rented network and perhaps
even regulated access okay so let's
start for them for the second question
probably if you know me so I I think I
do think that more things will come
regarding the potential partnership
agreement or sharing agreement across
the different operators because honestly
speaking if within in about the industry
whether we need to ensure is that we are
going to be as efficient as possible on
a smart as possible so I think that with
nothing written at this point of time I
think that if we are continue doing our
job this is something that potentially
we'd appear more in these or Perkins in
other technologies regarding your
question about the multi technology NJ
net worth at the we have been explained
we had two possibilities to look at it
so one is that that could be a weakness
okay because we have too many networks
to be managed in a different way
however in the way that that we are
doing this we transform that's potential
weakness into one of our biggest
strengths why is because honestly
speaking we are in such a way looking
for the end-to-end view from the
customer point of view
okay so I'm not looking at the network
just looking at my HF see my ftth our
selling agreement what to our wholesale
agreement we are trying with our
innovation and our tools as I was
mentioning also with with the concept of
home to have the end-to-end view of the
customer so we have the enforce to do
that kind of things due to our
particularities and I really believe
that this is transforming everyday into
an estranged for the near future so this
is more or less the way that we are
trying to to change this picture from
one side to the next turning to Fernanda
you've actually started your speech king
of describing masked marvel as the
forest and latest and a very late
entrant into the Spanish market and I
know from personal experience that it is
a tough place to be to be a challenger
so my question to you is what is really
the right business approach in your
experience to actually be successful as
such a very late entrant in a country
where you're actually really expected to
contribute to the fiber success story to
contribute to the fiber paradigm well
thank you for the question sir that it's
true that it's thought but it's fun on
the other side because you have a lot of
things that you can
and probably when you have a big legacy
there are many less things you can do so
you start from the scratch and there are
many decisions that I've been in the
other side as well and you can take when
you have that big legacy so you can do
things from the strand from the scratch
and learn from what the others have
already done so of course you need to
find your spot where can you make a
difference where can you do things that
where others have not been able to do
that or I still haven't arrived and so
this was the first point so we go to
others maybe others have not gone and
then we might have an opportunity to
make some difference but then you get
the advantage when you look for
efficiency of things that others have
already done and Raqqah has been
presented the economies of scale and the
learning curve and how to industrialize
the process well all that industry was
already there when we are right and in
the end we use the same people doing the
deployment on the streets and in
installation for the customers and those
people fortunately for us we didn't have
to teach them we just have to go there
and pick them and in fact there had been
a consolidation in the market what means
that some of these companies were
willing to have new customers to go and
say ok you also want to deploy we are
willing to work with you to add some
more deployment and that was helped him
to something that for a new entrant with
limited resources is very important that
is efficiency also for efficiency we
took advantage also of some regulatory
things like that access from telefónica
like facade deployment so some things
were already there in the industry and
we didn't have to fight for them and so
there are some advantages even as
internal resources we have access to
some very knowledgeable resources that
were out in the market because the
consolidation brings also some
opportunities for people to move from
one side to the other and and so we have
also a number of people that were
already knowledgeable that were willing
to come to this new project and going
further into that efficiency
and as my colleagues had mentioned go
invest it in investing and taking the
decision to to work together with other
with other companies was almost a must
so you cannot arrive late have limited
resources and decide that you are going
to make the difference by going alone to
different places but if you if you want
to grow you need to cooperate with
others not just with the big players
that are sitting here when I was in my
former life in other company I didn't
know that the smaller operators existed
but they exist and so when you are a
smaller lead you go out there and you
say who are these guys what are they
doing I mean there are hundreds of small
operators operating in small towns
having their own local operation in the
town that if you want you you can find
agreements also even with some of those
guys that are good enough or big enough
to make some agreements so that's part
of the things that helped you be
efficient in how to grow and also start
getting some scale can you get enough
scale to be competitive at a national
level just by doing that starting from
the scratch having limited resources
clearly not so you need to go also and
find some wholesale agreements there are
wholesale agreements that we have with
with orange we have signed some other
wholesale agreements with some other
small operators that are doing some
niche deployments in some other areas
and of course there is the regulated
access were well it's another
opportunity that we have to have access
then to all the deployment that is been
done also for example by by telephone
eager with a regulated price and of
course there are non regulated areas and
for us being a small company it's
important that the weight has already
been regulated the volume of of building
units that are non regulated is
significant so our messages do not keep
growing that because that that will not
allow us to have this K to be
competitive nationally and to have also
a fair price in the access to that
wholesale agreement is relevant for us
I think that commercial we've been able
to negotiate those things with orange
and now we will have access likely to
the regulated part of of telefónica and
that gives us the scale so there you
have the opportunity the spot so find
the spot the opportunity find the
efficiency where we had have had the
advantage of others having done that
before but have had to work in Co
investing and finding agreements to be
efficient and get the scale and for that
also
wholesale agreements of regulation that
has been that has been keep and key for
us thank you
I would like to turn back to Enrique for
a second
looking much more into the future and as
it has been mentioned by many of the
speakers and in the opening keynote
sessions 5g is a real buzz word and the
industry as well as in policy making
circles and there is a general
expectation of its kind of
transformational nature given that you
already have a very widespread fibre
network do you think that that's going
to be an advantage and how do you plan
to leverage your fiber network to deploy
5g so let me let me elaborate a little
bit more so 5g it is for sure new radio
capabilities so fast we know it we have
been working as an industry very hard
defining one means 5g new radio
capabilities but did you think that
fight it is just the new radio
capabilities it is new on Tina's new
processes new capabilities and this is
going to happen anyway and this is going
to help us trying to manage some
millions of sensors or devices per
square kilometer that we can not fully
support today so and this is going to
happen so all of us we are working all
of us we're testing massive memory
whatever which is the flavor that we are
testing so all of us we are doing all
our field trials labs and testing in
real so this is happening and but there
are two additional levels that will be
fully supported that this happen though
the first one it is what we will be
doing with the beautiful ization and the
architecture of the 5g networks
but this is key so telefónica seven
years ago we decided so that we will be
the trend to do a pioneer what means to
brutalize a network but what means
really so we are deploying in all our
country's network function brutalize it
so in a purist infrastructure that will
be fully supporting a clarification of
the network so and these are major words
the clarification of the network helping
us trying to define how will be the run
really clarify it how will be the narrow
slice it that will be helping us trying
to deploy services using a specific so
we are building not only the new radio
capabilities get in the new futures of
45 we go into 4G we are building the
topology and architecture that will be
fully supporting the 5g but with these
two levels this is not enough
because hey guys if you know what means
the bajalia for the 5g so this means
that today we are fully supporting 4G
using microwaves and some kind of
capabilities around one Giga pers per
second this is not enough we need to
connect in the urban and dense
capabilities of fiber with at least five
gigabit per second and this means an
capillarity and ninis are powerful in
the fiber connection to the base station
for the fighty that we'll be needing
first of all be solvent in the tens are
s in the densities but if we try to go
through the rest so interesting
discussion and how we can share and how
we can discuss how this can be feasible
so this will be a must
fiber for sure dense and durable
capabilities for sure but with TC levels
but discussion very interesting because
if we decide to do the same that we did
with a 2g with a 3G and with the 4G so
it will be amazing discussion how will
be about the cost of this party thank
you
I actually have a very last question of
the keynote session and I would like to
address that to moneka
we do have a very important initiative
and the fiber-to-the-home council Europe
which has women and fiber with you know
with I think the very noble cause of
bringing bringing more gender balance
and more female talent and competencies
into the sector and obviously you are
the only female speaker in the sector
which is darhk's who dominated let's be
honest about it so could you tell us
about your experience and how you feel
as a women as a woman in such a dark
suit dominated sector well I feel very
well because they treat me very well and
I treat them very well but it's true
that women do not represent the 50% of
this of the tech sector and I do not
agree with the X Google employee who
said that women are underrepresented in
the tech sector because of inherent
psychological differences I think that
the only reason for being
underrepresented is because of the
social factor for instance generally
speaking parents encourage their sons to
be engineers more than their daughters
for this is why I extremely support to
increase the visibility of women in tech
because I think it's important to have
more and more role models for the
parents and also for the girls to show
that the business tech is also funny for
women I mean think that in this
visibility issue I think that we can do
it quite easily here in Spain because we
have important women in Spain occupying
top management positions in tech
companies such as IBM or Microsoft or
for instance the last telefónica as new
CEO for Spain who also is a warren so
the point is visibility thank you very
much
and thank you very much to all of our
distinguished panelists for this
extremely interesting discussion and I
really hope that we will continue
discussing over the lunch breaks coffee
breaks and the cocktail opportunities
how we can have more fiber rich
cps for europe but also more across the
globe thank you very much